and welcome back to Long crime everybody
Alec Murdock is locked up right now in a
South Carolina Prison he's serving two
life sentences for killing his wife and
son but the threat of future legal
proceedings still hangs over him during
his trial Murdoch took the stand to
testify in his own defense and he
admitted under oath that he lied about
practically everything hiding his
financial misdeeds as well as his opioid
addiction and in a separate case Murdoch
is facing 99 charges in six different
counties for stealing almost nine
million dollars from clients in his Law
Firm but what impact will his testimony
have on the fraud and embezzlement
charges in South Carolina there is a
statute that says that the prosecutors
cannot use his past testimony as proof
of wrongdoing in the financial crimes
cases so we asked a South Carolina
criminal defense attorney if it's even
worth to take Murdoch to trial again
he's already serving two consecutive
life sentences I mean from this is
politics from here on out there's
there's not a criminal justice reason to
have any additional trials there are
political reasons and so I'll
I can see in a high profile case that
the prosecution would not want to come
in and just dismiss Finance 99 Financial
crimes but it has no practical impact on
Mr Murdoch's life
meantime The Man convicted of conspiring
with Alec Murdoch to take money from his
clients legal settlements wants a new
trial Russell Lafitte is the former CEO
of Palmetto State Bank he filed a motion
in federal court saying that Murdoch's
testimony during the double murder trial
proves his innocence because Murdoch
testified that he committed the
embezzlement and fraud alone without
bringing one bringing anyone else on in
his schemes Lafitte says or believes
that that information will result in
acquittal for him on retrial in fact his
legal team also contends that there were
improper influences on the jury lafleet
was found guilifi was found guilty on
six counts of wire and bank fraud he's
been free on bail awaiting sentencing in
the federal case and Lafitte still faces
21 counts of financial crimes in state
courts so Brian what do you think of
this statutory law about statements on
the stand and how is that going to
affect Murdoch's future cases so someone
who practices in New York this blows my
mind because the first I think well this
is a statement against a party opponent
opponent sorry it is not hearsay because
it's literally an in court statement and
he's saying it under oath so why not use
it but then again as a defense attorney
I kind of say I want a bit of that I
want my client to be able to testify say
whatever he wants and not have it used
against him it sounds like he's
literally having his cake and eating it
too but you can use his statements for
the purpose of impeachment so if he does
try to play this game again he could get
impeached by what he said in the first
trial if he testifies to Future trials
so Terry is is he a mastermind though
did he know about this statute before he
took the stand absolutely and I
guarantee you he's not getting on stand
in the financial crimes case so I think
from the very beginning he said to
himself look I am going to weigh going
to jail for the murder of Paul and
Maggie or you know perhaps I can get off
in the financial crimes and I definitely
think he knew about that statute because
he was kind of vague when he testified
in his case in that murder case but he
did say and he did admit to you know
having lied to all of these individual
clients so now even on appeal he could
still win on appeal there's a chance of
that he could get out and then he goes
to the financial crimes case doesn't get
on the stand and you know has the chance
of perhaps winning I don't think that's
going to happen but well he might be a
terrible defendant but everybody said he
was a good lawyer but let's actually go
now to Salt Lake City where a female
soccer player at Westminster Westminster
College has filed a Title IX lawsuit
against the school and her soccer coach
according to court documents the student
alleges that female soccer players were
forced to sit in what was called the hot
seat on the team bus the lawsuit claims
that freshmen and transfer players were
asked intrusive questions about their
personal lives including sexual
experiences and preferences the team's
coach Tony LeBlanc reportedly played a
lead role in the questioning the planet
says that she filed a Title IX complaint
with Westminster College in 2021 when
she had to sit in the hot seat herself
but she says that the college wanted to
handle it as a Personnel matter the
lawsuit states that LeBlanc was put on a
short administrative leave but when he
came back he retaliated against the
student by benching her the lawsuit is
seeking damages with the amount to be
determined at an upcoming trial the
appearance of an 18 year old student who
died after a hazing event on the
Louisiana State University campus was
awarded more than six million dollars by
a jury Maxwell groover from an Atlanta
area suburb in Georgia died after taking
part in a Phi Delta Theta fraternity
ritual involved taking multiple long
chugs from a bottle of strong liquor an
autopsy found groover had a blood
alcohol content of 0.49 percent that is
six times the legal limit the most
recent sediment came from a case against
one of the former fraternity members in
his insurance company groover's parents
have already gotten money from
settlements with 17 other defendants in
the civil suit including LSU and the
fraternity
groover's parents say they plan to use
the money to fund the max groover
Foundation this is an organization that
wants to end hazing on college campuses
jury members they seem to be struggling
in the case of three men accused of
killing up-and-coming rap sensation
xxxtentacion down in Florida day four
verdict watch wrapping up and still no
decision now xxxtentacion's real name
was Jose onfroy in 2018 he was shot to
death and robbed while leaving a
motorcycle dealership prosecutors
presented a lengthy case pointing the
finger at Michael Boatright as the
trigger man Trayvon Newsom is the second
gunman and Diedrich Williams is the
ringleader and getaway driver the star
witness was another co-defendant Robert
Allen who pleaded guilty to
second-degree murder and robbery charges
he actually testified against his
alleged accomplices only one defense
team actually presented a case Michael
boat Wright's attorney he questioned a
Broward County sergeant and detective on
the stand in the hopes of poking holes
in the investigation the jury's gone
over Robert Allen's testimony
surveillance video and thousands of text
messages messages and social media posts
while the co-defendants guilt or
innocence may seem obvious to some we
asked trial attorney offie Patterson
what could be tripping up some of the
jurors
Newsome's attorney did a good job of
saying you know harping on the fact that
there's no DNA you know um there's
another person there who could be the
trigger person uh there are no
fingerprints there should be
fingerprints you know where is that so
there are some points that were made but
I don't think they were all strong
enough I think the issue is um the
charge is first degree murder it's a
very heavy charge and it may be hard for
jurors to say first degree murder for
everybody when everybody played a
different role and
a prosecutor could definitively put
every defendant there all right let's
make let's try to make sense event I'm
joined right now but my co-host defense
attorney Brian buckmeyer former trial
Attorney Terry Austin Terry the jury had
more questions today but it was mostly
about scheduling like how long should
the judge the judge allow the jury to
deliberate without providing some sort
of instruction to them you know
technically the judge has to allow them
to deliberate and they haven't said that
they are in any sort of Deadlock so he's
going to allow them to go ahead and
think about that case but I do think at
some point he's going to have to give
them some sort of Direction they've been
asking all of these questions about
transcripts as you mentioned about text
messages they want to hear almost all of
the evidence over again and he is just
basically saying let them do whatever
they want and he basically said as long
as they're happy he's happy I think he's
got to somehow rein them in and stop
being just concerned about how happy
they are well Brian I know it's like
reading tea leaves but scheduling
questions wanting to see so many of the
text messages what's going on in the
journey room right now Jesse I think
this is what we call a rogue jury Rogan
the sense that they heard what the
defense said they heard the prosecution
said they say you know what let's put
this to the side and let's figure this
out for ourselves and that's what I
think they're doing that's why they're
going through each and every piece of
these text messages and phone calls to
try to make sense of who is more
culpable than the other I don't think
the prosecution did a good enough job to
kind of paint the picture of in for a
penny in for a pound if you're part of
this Enterprise so to speak or or these
sets of crimes that lead to someone's
murder you're all guilty and I think the
defense had a good enough job poking a
few holes here and there so they're kind
of left to do it on their own well I
said it in our last broadcast I'm going
to say it again we will wait and see
what happens but there's new information
that was released Tuesday that shines a
new light on allegations of sexual
misconduct against former Cowboys wide
receiver Michael Irvin the Hall of Famer
held a news conference Tuesday to
release surveillance video of the
incident as he files a 100 million
dollar lawsuit against Marriott this
after Marriott made claims about the
incident at its Hotel Irvin claims he
was removed and his Super Bowl
appearances were canceled so here's what
we know we know that Irvin was staying
at a Renaissance Hotel in Arizona for
the Super Bowl in February when he
encountered a female employee near the
hotel lobby bar according to Marriott
Irvin made a lewd comment to the woman
making her very uncomfortable in a
statement Marriott said that Irvin
touched the woman's arm without her
consent and continued to get closer as
she tried to back away now Irvin was
able to get his hands on hotel security
video after multiple court orders last
week and in the video you can see Irvin
and the woman having a conversation as
he does briefly touch her arm but the
entire thing seems to be pretty cordial
beginning and ending with them shaking
hands after learning new details about
the incident Irvin's legal team moved
the lawsuit from federal court to State
Court in Arizona
but when you get called in a room and
you're saying somebody tells you hey
pack your bags
go home
I said what what happened new sexual
assault so who knew the Bible's in my
room well
don't worry about it go on yeah I'm just
thankful I'm just so thankful for those
Witnesses I'm so thankful
for this video
for this video because without it
I uh
I just don't know where this would would
have gone
and staying in the sports realm good
news for former NBA All-Star Sean Kemp
prosecutors in Washington state are not
going to be filing charges against him
after a shooting last week on Wednesday
Tacoma police arrested Sean Kemp a
former standout for the Seattle
SuperSonics in a mall parking lot they
said that he had been involved in a
drive-by shooting with another car now
Kemp's lawyer said that his car had been
broken into the day before and items
were stolen including his phone now he
ended up tracking it to a car at the
Tacoma Mall but he when he went when he
went to confront the people inside they
allegedly started shooting at him so he
shot back the Pierce County prosecutor's
office says that it won't file charges
pending further investigation